alors on est au boulodrome de tours et
on reçoit les meilleures nations du
monde suivez moi on va s'installer là
alors faut pas faire trop de bruit parce
que ils n'auront pas le sage ou et ils
s'en branlent nous volent ils sont pas
maliens
c'est plaisant car il ya des
l'animation et puis la plaisanterie
qu'est ce qui s'est passé à guy roux
tout à lèvres commence à perdre son
pantalon avec la part le parc a trop la
tendance à oui c'est plus petit en bas
quand je guide région de série à tomber
par terre
il s'est attaqué l'un des sept à neuf
mais ils ont plus en plus de moyens mais
bon on va passer de l'autre côté des
gradins on a un commentateur sur le côté
là rien n'était encore debout et il
commande sur la chaîne fr3 et de l'achat
des fertois tôt fait ouais ouais ouais
d'accord sur une chaîne et les cats et
dont on a parlé tout à l'heure et après
de faire une démonstration seul arbitre
on voulait faire une interview des
rayures pour savoir dans quel sens
pourquoi il était dans ce sens là alors
moi on m'a dit un truc est ce que c'est
vrai que c'était pour les différencier
les prisons ben voilà meilleurs alors je
peux dire que les autres ça vaut pas
mais ça fait rien ils sont bons ils sont
bons on met un carton il fait des
remarques aller philippe vient de finir
on va les mettre à prouver bien à quoi
on joue là maintenant au final de
vacances après ça va être sérieux tu
joues que je dis oui et puis il a été
commentée interrompue sur la journée il
faut des organisateurs il faut des
organisateurs 22h 22h30 sa marathon la
pétanque sport moi je les comparer au
décathlon un décathlonien il commence le
matin fini le soir vous avez glissé sur
une boule à non pas du tout joe autre
femme
non pas du tout expliquez moi parce que
s'il est besoin d'un remplaçant je sais
comment c'est du dur de l'usure à de
l'usure
je suis très derrière du peloton c'est
bon ça s'appelait sata plus très bien eh
ben c'est bien
merci à vous d'aller à la paix tant que
c'est un sport dangereux
oui
ces 700 grammes la boule pour certains
oui ceux qui se contrôle pas oui petite
anecdote il ya samedi dernier un joueur
a perdu il a mis un coup de boule mais
avec la tête à l'adversaire carton rouge
élimination la fédération va lui enlever
sa licence à y jouer réellement bolloré
en championnat d'éclat en championnat
des clubs
c'est le reflet de la société
tout simplement regardent ils ont du
boulot maintenant il faut que j'aille
les aider alors on a passé un bon moment
mais tous les bons moments où une fin à
la prochaine à bientôt didier merci à
bientôt
[Musique]